[Music]
bond fans certainly can cherry pick
their favorites but there's really only
one way to view these adventures as the
work of one semi-ageless operative and
it's not in chronological order you've
been watching james bond movies all
wrong and here's why to start at the
character's beginning means 2006's
casino royale the franchise reboot that
served as daniel craig's bond debut
based on fleming's first bond novel the
film gives bond a gritty origin story in
which he earns his double o status
drives off with his signature aston
martin and uses his brawn as well as his
wits like when he flings an empty
handgun right back in an opponent's face
most importantly the film refreshes the
trope of a woman who does him wrong by
having a genuine love story with an
unwilling betrayal eva green's treasury
liaison vesper lind throws real sparks
with craig revealing a striking
complexity beneath bond's flinty gaze
phoebe waller bridge the fleabag star
and co-screenwriter of no time to die
told gq he let us in a bit which makes
the moment he shuts us out even more
arresting overall he grounded a fantasy
character in real emotion which is what
i think we hadn't realized we'd missed
amongst the action and the bravado
quantum of solace released in 2008 picks
up where casino royale left off with
bond discovering that criminal banker le
chef is part of a larger terrorist
organization called quantum he also
ferrets out more about vesper's past
unfortunately the writers guild strike
at the time hampered a cohesive plot
with craig admitting to gq we didn't
have a script so we concentrated a lot
on the stunts craig's third outing
skyfall continued to develop bond as a
character particularly his relationship
with m after a botched mission with new
agent eve bond is presumed dead but when
vengeful ex-agent raul silva targets m
and mi6 bond returns as m's protector
taking her to skyfall his childhood home
in the scottish highlands there viewers
see the headstones of his parents and
their surname confirms that james bond
is the same character across the
franchise admittedly one without much of
a secret identity bond defeats silva but
em dies throwing off the continuity when
dench turns up in the pierce brosnan
years
as much as the craig films service bonds
origin story 2015 spectre also delves
into his connection with the criminal
organization a frequent adversary from
fleming's novels on the trail of mr
white a character from casino royale and
quantum of solace bond learns that the
quantum organization is a specter
subsidiary he also meets white's
daughter psychologist madeleine swann
the two follow spectres trail to morocco
where they wind up prisoners of a man
bond recognizes as franz oberhauser son
of a foster father from bond's youth
oberhauser reveals that his current name
is ernst avro blowfilm which rings a
bell for bond aficionados as oberhauser
he'd faked his death and now he's in
charge of spectre which has an mi6 mole
with designs on a global surveillance
network of course bond foils blofeld's
plan then drives off with swan leaving
espionage behind no time to die forces
him back into the field as cia pal felix
lighter asks him for help in pursuing
sapphic an anarchist and ex-specter
assassin meanwhile blofeld stirs up
trouble while in custody and a secret
from swan's past surfaces it's safe to
assume that whatever else no time to die
has in store bond's relationship with
swan won't survive
dr note released in 1962 officially
introduced moviegoers to fleming's
secret agent along with the concept of
the bond girl and an eccentric power
crazy villain sean connery's bond heads
to jamaica to investigate the slaying of
another british agent discovering that
the death is connected to recent
sabotage of the u.s space program his
investigation leads to a private island
where he encounters honey ryder a
gorgeous diver searching for seashells
the two meet the island's owner dr
julius know a spectre agent and nuclear
scientist aiming to take over a u.s
rocket launch as revenge for both the
americans and the east not recognizing
his genius thanks to bond his plans end
in a meltdown connery's follow-up 1963's
from russia with love further explores
spectre and its nefarious plans as bond
goes undercover to meet tatiana romanova
a russian cipher clerk wanting to defect
with the decoder device she turns out to
be an unwitting pawn in a spectre
assassination plot against bonn for
killing dr noah bond strangles one
specter assassin and goes toe-to-toe
with another wielding a poison spike in
her shoe romanova comes to his defense
proving that love conquers all
definitely one of the most memorable
bond films goldfinger finds bond looking
into orrick goldfinger a gold magnate
who smuggles the stuff out of england
through the body work of his rolls royce
but goldfinger has a grander scheme in
mind destroying the gold reserve in fort
knox with an atomic bomb rendering it
useless and thus cementing his wealth to
enter fort knox goldfinger enlists an
elite squad of female pilots to spray
nerve gas which will kill thousands bond
wins over the improbably named squadron
leader [ __ ] galore before stopping the
bomb with a precise double-oh-seven
seconds to spare connery told the new
york times at the time
it sort of demonstrates what i believe
is a subtler more discriminating bond
than you've seen in the earlier films i
guess i'm trying to make james bond grow
up a little in the same way that i'm
growing up myself not too much though
definitely not too much that would spoil
the fun for both of us
thunderball released in 1965 sends bond
to the bahamas to recover two nuclear
warheads that emilio largo seconded
command inspector hijacks for ransom
swiping them involved brainwashing a
pilot and sending him for plastic
surgery something bond discovers while
visiting a health spa for some r r under
m's orders eventually bond pieces
together that the brainwashed pilot whom
spectre kills is the brother of domino
largo's mistress you only live twice
released in 1967 showed connery's bond
at last meeting spectre leader earned
stavro blofeld after an attempt on
bond's life complete with a burial at
sea bond re-emerges and joins forces
with tiger tanaka of japanese
intelligence tanaka suggests that bond
mary to pose as a local fisherman so he
can investigate undercover the bride is
another agent kissy suzuki who is all
business the two uncover a secret
spectre base within a volcano where
blofeld hoped to deceive the soviets and
americans it's starting world war three
with those plans thwarted kissy and bond
decide to enjoy their honeymoon until
mi6 interrupts
australian actor george lazenby stepped
into bond's shoes in 1969's on her
majesty's secret service after he
rescues the suicidal contested tracy de
vincenzo from drowning in the opening
moments she drives away leaving bond
dumbstruck and spurring theories of
james bond being a code name with a
cheekiest side to the camera
this never happened to the other fella
the espionage plot is a little kooky
this time around with blowfeld running
an allergy clinic in the swiss alps
that's really a way to brainwash
attendees into distributing biological
warfare but that's secondary to bond's
relationship with tracy the spirited but
troubled daughter of a mob boss tracy a
skilled skier as well as driver gamely
helps bond throughout the movie and the
two marry toward the film's end then
blofeld and an assassin pepper their car
with bullets after the ceremony killing
tracy and leaving bond poignantly
holding her behind the shattered
windshield
connery returned as bond in 1971's
diamonds are forever which begins with
him tracking down blofeld to an
underground layer where the spectre
leader prepares for plastic surgery bond
ties blofeld to an operating table and
plunges it into a steaming mud lake
presumably avenging tracy's death
although his late wife isn't mentioned
elsewhere in the film welcome to hell
blue felt
as bond investigates who is stealing
huge quantities of diamonds he learns
that the blowfeld in the lair was
actually a double for the real blofeld
currently hanging out in las vegas under
the guise of multi-millionaire willard
white with the help of conniving jewel
smuggler tiffany case bond figures out
that the diamonds are powering a space
satellite and laser aimed at nuclear
installations around the world they
stopped the destruction of course
although tiffany wonders if there's any
way to get those sparklers back to earth
roger moore took over as double 07 in
1973's live and let die more definitely
brought a lighter touch to bond but this
film's blaxploitation influences haven't
aged well
well you just keep on the tail of that
jukebox and there's an extra 20 in it
for you hey man
for 20 bucks i'll take you to a ku klux
klan cookout
the plot is bond checking out a heroin
operation controlled by a caribbean
dictator and a gangster both of whom are
actually the same person in disguise
there's a lengthy motorboat chase a
wince inducing southern sheriff
alligators voodoo and some duplicitous
consent with the film's women
blaxploitation actress gloria hendry
playing a field agent and the tarot
reader solitaire moore's next bond film
1974's the man with the golden gun finds
himself the target of francisco
scaramonga the world's most expensive
assassin who kills with a single shot
from a specialized weapon bond also
delves into the work of a scientist
wanting to harness the sun's power to
solve the energy crisis when m calls him
off that mission for his safety bond
ignores him learning that skara manga is
after not just bond as a trophy but the
solar technology as well
with spectre seemingly gone the bond
films of the 1970s into the 1990s
focused more on cold war antagonists the
spy who loved me from 1977 does that
with the cheekiness and excess of the
more era but for some reason it all
works when british and soviet nuclear
submarines vanish bond follows a lead to
cairo where he runs across russian major
anya mosuvo working the case from the
soviet end the two form a tenuous
alliance to defeat wealthy shipping
entrepreneur carl stromberg who wants
the submarines to launch armageddon so
he can create a new civilization beneath
the sea stromberg likes sharks that
devour enemies and has a metal tooth
henchmen named jaws for all its flash
the film also has a notable callback to
bond's late wife tracy many lady friends
but married only once wife killed right
you've made your point
blame the success of star wars for
launching bond into space with 1979's
moonraker a film that copies the basic
plot of the spy who loved me with that
film's henchman jaws now working for a
different megalomaniac who wants to kill
people and start over fresh this time
hugo drax a supplier of space shuttles
to the us government makes off with a
shuttle to transport a new master race
to a space station it's not enough to
leave earth behind though drax also has
concocted a lethal toxin to kill the not
so worthy humans trapped on the planet
the film includes a wild chase through
venice where a gondola becomes a
hovercraft and a full-on laser battle in
space bond also gets a hand from one of
the smarter women of the moore era an
astronaut and cia agent with the eye
rolling name of holly goodhead at least
she can pile it to shuttle
bond went more down to earth for 1981's
for your eyes only the agent searched
the mediterranean for a missing british
ship equipped with a weapons encryption
device meaning molina havelock a
crossbow wielding woman whose parents
worked with the british government her
quest for revenge against whoever killed
them dovetails with the secret kgb agent
christatos and a greek smuggler the film
includes realistic action scenes both
underwater and during a mountain
climbing climax but first it closes the
book on spectre in the opening moments
as bond visits the grave of his late
wife tracy a helicopter arrives to whisk
him back to mi6 once in the air a surge
of electricity through the headset kills
the pilot and blowfeld now using a
wheelchair takes control of the craft
from the ground the agent manages to rip
out cables connecting blowfeld's remote
control then flies after his one-time
nemesis scooping up the wheelchair on
one of the chopper's skids and dropping
him down a smokestack
for moore's final two bond outings the
agent again dealt with cold war
machinations in 1983's octopussy bond
becomes involved with a jewelry smuggler
and circus owner who gives the film its
title she's in league with exiled afghan
prince kamal khan who's actually using
her circus operation to stage a nuclear
accident with a rogue soviet general
there are acrobatic thieves a hunt in
india that's an homage to the short
story the most dangerous game and
disguises for bonds that include an ape
costume and a clown suit moore hung up
his walther ppk after 1985's a view to a
kill which pitted bond against
industrialist max soaring a psychopath
thanks to failed soviet steroid
experiments
zorin has a striking henchwoman named
mayday and designs on destroying silicon
valley through an earthquake so he can
control the microchip market naturally a
san francisco geologist helps bond
disrupt zorin's plans resulting in a
showdown atop the landmark golden gate
bridge
royal shakespeare company actor timothy
dalton starred as bond in 1987's the
living daylights as the guardian noted
his more nuanced and complex
interpretation hewed closer to fleming's
novels but perplexed fans accustomed to
the quippy more years dalton is
introduced during a training exercise at
the rock of gibraltar where an assassin
picks off several agents until the film
reveals the new double07 defecting kgb
general georgie koskov says his former
superior has revived a spy assassination
program but bond later learns that
koskov is in league with an american
arms dealer and wants the man dead for
business reasons
because of the aids epidemic bond is a
one-woman man this time around forging a
romance with kara molovy a cellist who
had been koskov's girlfriend dalton's
follow-up 1989's license to kill finds
bond on a cold-blooded personal crusade
against a drug dealer whose men leave
felix lighter for dead and kill his
bride della before her death della
wonders why their friend james hasn't
found a steady sweetheart and felix
briefly explains that he was once
married because of legal issues bond
didn't return to theaters until 1995's
goldeneye which starred pierce brosnan
after dalton resigned the film starts
about a decade before the present day
with bond on a job with fellow double o
agent and friend alec trevelyan who
seemingly dies of course events in
bond's life are rarely what they appear
and bond later learns that alec is alive
and leading a crime syndicate he seeks a
satellite-based electromagnetic pulse
weapon known as goldeneye the filmmakers
attempted to update bond for modern
audiences by giving him a female m who
criticizes him i think you're a sexist
misogynist dinosaur a relic of the cold
war but some bond things never change
they also gave alec a leggy accomplice
zhenya anatom who likes to crush victims
between her thighs bond gets some
assistance from a cia contact who
disconcertingly calls bond jimbo as well
as natalya a russian computer programmer
who flirts with getting bond to settle
down
brosnan's second doubting 1997's
tomorrow never dies explores more of
bond's past by introducing a former
girlfriend paris now married to eliot
carver a tabloid media mogul carver
draws mi6's attention after a spurious
signal from one of his company's
communication satellites occurs at the
same time a british warship sinks in
chinese waters paris helps bond
infiltrate her husband's headquarters
for old time's sake for which carver has
her killed carver has a more unusual
scheme for a bond villain he wants to
secure exclusive broadcasting rights in
china in exchange for starting a war
between the british and the chinese
fortunately bond finds an ally in weilin
a chinese agent who can handle herself
1999's the world is not enough packed an
impressive twist at m's request bond
retrieves money from a swiss banker for
british oil tycoons to robert king a
particular sum that turns out to be
treated with an explosive bond deduces
that someone wanted to send a message by
killing king through the cash because
king's daughter elektra had recently
been ransomed for the same amount of
money although he presumes that the
terrorist who kidnapped elektra is
responsible king's killer turns out to
be elektra herself she's developed
feelings for her kidnapper and the two
want to detonate a nuclear explosion in
istanbul leaving the king pipeline the
only viable route for extracting
petroleum from that region along to
diffuse the situation as a nuclear
physicist with the eye roll inducing
name of dr christmas jones
brosnan's 10 years bond finished in
2002's die another day released the same
year as the 40th anniversary of dr no
the film pays homage in some ways to
other previous blonde films and
fleming's novels one such nod having
bond pick up the book a field guide to
birds of the west indies whose author
james bond inspired the name of
fleming's famous spy the plot mirrors
some elements of previous entries with
an adversary whom bond thought was dead
assuming a new identity to build a space
laser out of diamonds nsa agent jinx
johnson teams up with bond in a story
that becomes more fantastical than some
fans liked bond surfs through an iceberg
tsunami there's an ice palace and the
aston martin vanquish becomes invisible
although he felt shocked over being
replaced at first brosnan in 2020 said
he has quote no regret over his double
07 days telling the guardian bond is the
gift that keeps giving and has allowed
me to have a wonderful career once
you're branded as a bond it's with you
forever check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite iconic film
franchises are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you